- We already know a good
bit about negative numbers.
And we know a good bit of fractions.
So you can imagine we're
going to start seeing
negatives and fractions together a lot.
What I want to do in this video
is just make sure we have
a decent understanding
how to manipulate negative signs
when we see them in fractions.
For example, if I have
the fraction negative 1/2.
Here I have the negative out
in front of the entire 1/2.
This is the same thing
as negative one over two.
And it's going to be the same thing
as one over negative two.
Now I could also think
about something like
negative one over negative two.
Now it's important to realize
one way to think about
this as a fraction is you could view this
as negative one divided by negative two.
And we already know, if
you divide a negative
by a negative it would be a positive.
So this right over here is going to be
the same thing as 1/2.
This is going to be the
same thing as positive 1/2.
Now with that out of the way,
let's think a little bit.
Let's do some example
problems that might push
our thinking on this a little bit more.
So this first question.
Which of the following expressions
are equivalent to negative g over h?
Negative G over H.
Select all that apply.
All right, so this has all
sorts of negatives here.
So at first it looks a little bit unusual.
But then we need to just
realize that this part.
Actually, let me just square this off in
blue right over here.
Negative g over negative h.
We've already figured that out.
We actually looked at
that right over here.
If you have a negative
divided by a negative,
that's the same thing as a positive value
divided by the positive value.
So negative g over negative h,
is the same thing as g over h.
And then you still have
this negative out front.
You still have that negative out front.
So this one right over here is actually
equal to negative g over h.
When we think about it,
negative divided by a negative
is a positive and you still
have this negative out here.
So that's the same thing.
And this right over
here, negative in front.
And then you have g over negative h.
This is going to be the same thing.
You could rewrite this, you
could put the negative on top
as negative g over negative h.
And then this would be equal to g over h,
which is different.
This is positive g over h.
This is negative g over h.
So we wouldn't select that.
And of course we wouldn't
select "None of the above."
Cause we found a choice that we liked.
All right.
Which of the following
expressions are equivalent
to five over b.
Select all that apply.
All right, so this one over here.
Negative five over negative b.
Well we could remember that this negative,
we could write this is the
same thing as negative five
over negative b.
And I just want to make it
clear we're that negative.
So this is negative
Instead of writing it negative
in front of the entire fraction,
I could essentially
multiply the negative one
times just the numerator.
So you could write this as
negative five over negative b.
And negative divided by a negative
is going to be a positive.
So this actually is going to be equal to
positive five over b, which
is what we're looking for.
So this is going to be right.
Now this one, negative
divided by a negative,
well that's just going to be positive.
So that's the same thing as five over b.
One way to think about it
is that well the negatives
kind of cancel each other out.
So five over b, that looks good too.
And of course I won't
select none of the above
because I found two choices that worked.
All right, let's do one more.
Which of the following expressions
are equal to negative e over negative f?
And remember we just have to
take this step by step here.
Actually let's try to just
simplify this directly.
So negative e
over negative f.
Well we just need to remind ourselves
that this part right over here.
Negative e over negative f.
Let me write an equal sign.
Negative e over, and I'm
gonna put this negative.
Let me do this in a different color.
Let me do this in purple.
So we have this purple.
So we have that purple
negative right over there.
And negative e over negative f.
We've already talked
about this multiple times.
That's the same thing as negative's
divided by a negative is a positive.
That's the same thing as e over f,
as positive e over f.
So this whole thing will simplify to
negative e over f.
So let's see which of
these choices are that.
Well this right here is positive e over f.
So that's not the choice.
This one over here.
This one we could write
it several ways actually.
We could write it negative
negative e over f.
Which of course is equal
to positive e over f.
We could also write this.
We could put the negative
in the denominator.
We could say that this thing.
Actually let me write it over here
as negative e over negative f.
This is also a legitimate thing to do.
You could take this negative
and multiply it times the denominator.
Right over here.
But either way it's going to
be equal to positive e over f.
These two are actually evaluate
to the same expression.
So here, I would select.
Finally, I would select.
I've been waiting to
select "None of the above."
All right, hopefully that helps.